many people will be excited and relieved
for the announcement this afternoon that
we're moving out of a looot level 3 this
return to some normality will be
welcomed by some while others will be
choosing to stay at home and feeling a
degree of concern or perhaps confusion
it's perfectly okay and normal that we
will all feel differently about this
decision please continue to be kind in
supportive of others getting down to the
solute level so quickly is due to the
efforts of every New Zealander so a big
thanks to all our community for playing
their part and making this a success so
far now we are at elite level to the
council can open up our public
facilities like playgrounds and parks
something I'm sure parents across the
district will be very happy about and
over time we will be able to return to
offering the full range of services
council service centers libraries and
aquatic centers will be progressively
opened although some services may not
resume where they can't be delivered
safely reopening of community halls will
be delayed given issues with trekking
people visiting these unnamed facilities
further information will be provided in
the coming days for the most up-to-date
info on what facilities and services are
opening including the safety measures
put in place please visit Waimakariri
dot govt T dot Ian's Eid /co vat19 in
addition to council services many of our
local businesses will also be open
please where you are able play your part
in shop local to help these businesses
bounce back until next time stay safe in
be kind
you